this is going to get dark because we are
now in the true depths of the hunter
hunter Iceberg Hunter is notably not
always a bright and wacky fun series and
tagashi often allows it to drift into a
bit of a disturbing Abyss a lot of which
you may not even pick up on there are
some very subtle and very shockingly
depressing stuff in Hunter Hunter and
after I've pointed it out you won't be
able to unseal before we get to that
though first up as promised at the end
of our previous video there is a second
hidden nen language in this world known
only as the Divine script an incredibly
remarkable and game-changing
augmentation of nen utilized by a
completely unremarkable character which
is the pirate boxer on Greed Island
within his ring was the Divine script
which functions sort of like in an
inscription except rather than being
programmed for a specific purpose it
gives off more of a general nen buff
says Gara recognizes the script in the
series and he remarks that the pirate
boxer may as well be advertising just
how weak he is implying the boxer is
only making use of the Divine script in
order to compensate for his complete and
utter lack of substance this is a
straight up nen buff and it makes me
wonder why no one else is using it but
then I realized someone else is using it
the Divine script was actually
introduced during York New City through
dalzalena whose sword is covered in the
nen enhancing writing and then he tries
to stab UVA game but the blade just
snaps so pretty pathetic showing from
the Divine script there and the 1999
anime agreed which is why in the 1999
version they make a big deal about
Dazzle in his Divine script by giving
him a power simula Aura and the sword is
actually capable of piercing uvagin
somewhat not totally but it gets in
there but then because the sword is
still intact later on the Phantom troop
then use it to kill dazzalena in the
same episode which is a change that I'm
not entirely sure why was made in the
manga he dies because Fink's rather
rudely I might add sticks his whole arm
through his chest which yes is a bit
brutal but the 1999 anime is much more
well known for embracing that sphere of
Darkness but I guess that in summation
the Divine script is kind of like the
poor man's version of net inscription
the slight buff utilized by lower level
nin uses over there and then the poor
Corner that basically gives away their
complete lack of ability to more veteran
users but having brought up the 1999
version this would not be an iceberg
video if we didn't address an awkward
bath scene I don't understand but for
whatever reason they could not get
enough of non-canon baths and showers
this went so far that they started
changing the setting of actual scenes in
the manga to put them in a shower when
they were not previously in a shower in
this case ubergin goes on a bit of a
rampage trying to find karapika and ends
up questioning and killing this dude in
his underwear but for whatever reason in
the 1999 version they have the scene
take place within a shower implying that
uvergine just intruded on this dude who
is for some reason showering in his
underwear and I guess that's that's just
how this interrogation is going to be
quite perplexing but then again tagashi
also has his fair share of oddities in
the main series as well because did you
know that hina's hat is actually alive
who's heena you ask and that's that's a
good question Hina is the Chimera ant
best known for getting pregante with an
end curse but then it went away once
chitu's skull was crushed by silver
she's an Annex cyst and one of the few
surviving Chimera ants but with a very
strange Quirk which is her living hat if
you pay special attention to heena's cap
you'll notice that it actually mimics
hina's Expressions so if she is
concerned then the hat is concerned and
if Hina is happy then the hat is happy
and so on and so forth for all of the
other emotions I mean I can't remember
them all off the top of my head because
it's just been a while since I felt
anything but what I do remember is what
was on the top of hina's head because
this hat is almost certainly a use of
net Ina being a specialist does have
access to wee and Abstract Powers it
could be an end Beast or it could even
be Hino herself perpetually manipulating
the nature of clothing you know come to
think of it where did the Chimera ants
even get their clothes like there was a
koala dressed in a full suit and I
suppose as time goes on they just sort
of hatch with clothes on already or at
least that's what Pito did so maybe all
of their clothing is alive and I'm not
done with this Royal commission into
Hunter Hunter fashion just yet he goes
best boy kilua also has a lot of
questions to answer regarding his pants
to be perfectly straightforward they are
impossible after a certain point in the
series series kilowatt starts casually
wandering around with two yo-yos each
weighing 50 kilograms each that's about
110 pound units for the like three
countries in the world that don't use
the metric system you should you should
get on that but either way it's it's a
lot of weight much more than your
average human can just casually wander
around with and certainly more than your
average pants can support kilos pants
are so powerful that they can house at
least 100 kilograms of weight which I
imagine is only possible due to some
sort of secret zoldic fabric production
like maybe they get their clothes
specially made by some sort of nen
seamstress but the issue with that is
that kilowatt is a boy who enjoys his
fashion and he definitely doesn't go
home to get specials old at clothing
every time he changes or any of the
times so somehow he keeps finding new
pants capable of harnessing these yoyos
meaning that it's more likely that there
is some sort of effect applied to the
yoyos that reduce the impact of their
weight but even more likely than that is
that Togashi just doesn't care and
implemented this without considering the
true Integrity of kilwa's pants now just
on the zaldics is a question what is the
difference between an assassin and a
serial killer the answer is that one is
a profession and one is a hobby and a
super obscure hobbyist in the world of
Hunter was a man by the name of Benny
Delon he's a renowned serial killer who
lived about a hundred years before
modern day Hunter Hunter who combined
his skill as a blacksmith with his hobby
of brutally kill murdering people and
you may not remember this character at
all but we know a pretty shocking amount
about his history including the fact
that he was a cult leader as well as
that the historical classification of
his murders can be defined into three
artistic periods and even a direct quote
from Benny himself who allegedly said
each of my victims screams and facial
expressions inspired my work because
basically what he would do is since he
would kill someone and then he would
craft a blade in response to the feeling
he got that was his art the blades
represent the feeling he had from
killing the person or the feeling the
person had from The Killing no don't
want to know but what I do know is that
Benny Delon actually forms a pivotal
part of the York New City Arc because
when crawler fights against both Zeno
and silver zaldick he uses a Benny Delon
knife which Silva and immediately
recognizes and is even able to correctly
place one artistic period it falls into
like the true death connoisseur he is in
fact that's why Silva was able to
survive this encounter at all because he
instantly knew the knife was toxic and
exactly how to deal with it and it's
stuff like that that really grips me
with Hunter Hunter this almost
unnecessary detail that builds the
characters in such wonderfully deep ways
Rolo has this knife because he is a
skilled killer and Silva recognizes the
knife because killing is his profession
it's like two contemporary artists
meeting to discuss the work had also
gone in kiloba find a completely
different Benny Delon knife several
chapters earlier which killer will
recognizes because of course he has also
studied the art of death just like his
father however gone is the one who
noticed that the knife was emanating
Aura meaning that Benny Delon was a nen
user and quite the Sinister one of that
and these knives are very potentially
conjured objects but Benny isn't the
only historical figure who knew nem and
I think you'll probably have heard of
this next one because did you know that
Jesus Christ was a nen user stick with
me here because Christianity is
confirmed to exist in the hunt hunt
World due to chapter 74 where crowler
mentions both Jesus and Judas by name
and if Jesus did in fact exist in this
world then the only logical conclusion
is that he was a nen user a very
powersome nen user because all of his
miracles can be explained through Aura
like the story of passing around the
infinite fish and the bread that's just
Jesus Conjuring food and even coming
back from the dead is an invocation to
post-mortem Nan because if hisoka can do
it then so can a theoretical fictional
Jesus and tagashi does often like to
include elements of reality into the
fiction of Hunter Hunter however I will
say that when he does that it's often
used in very dark ways which is a device
that I call togashi's realism because
Hunter Hunter aesthetically is a flat
series even before tagashi's health
problems it is characterized by a plain
and simple design when it comes to
characters with faces often featuring
little to no shading not saying that's a
bad thing I'm just saying that's his
style which makes it incredibly shocking
when you turn the page and see something
like this in chapter 90 there is a panel
that haunts me to this day because out
of nowhere where we cut to this shot of
four photorealistically drawn children
sitting against a wall and in the very
next shot we are back to reality or the
fictional reality as Nobunaga and Machi
walk right past them with kilowatt
monitoring from afar but why did we have
this panel to begin with and why was it
drawn so damn realistically I mean it's
undeniably impactful it smacks you right
in the balls and says hey pay attention
to me and not at all surprisingly both
anime versions did elect not even to
bother attempting what tagashi did here
in the 1999 version we get an out of
focus shot of the kids in the dark
completely devoid of facial features
almost in Stark opposition to what
Togashi put into the manga and then in
2011 the kids get cut almost completely
with all the remains of them being this
one shot of legs and a backpack but in
the manga it remains one haunting moment
of realism I suppose like a lot of art
what you meant to take from this panel
is very much up to your own personal
interpretation but there are other
examples of tagashi realism that um how
shall we say Less open for debate and
these take the form of morena's
motivation Morena prudo is a relatively
really recent character in the series
whose goal is simply to watch the world
burn and accompanying her mission
statement is a collage of images
designed to sum up morena's view of the
world containing everything from basic
principles of nature to the true depths
of human evil and what's more is that a
lot of these images were pretty much
taken one for one from real life human
events and I'm gonna say this right now
some of what I am about to say may get
this video age restricted or demonetized
and also some of you may find these
images genuinely disturbing because well
that's why tagashi decided to use them
but this collage contains a whole host
of Togashi redrawing famous images from
the world of photojournalism including
Starving Children lynchings Isis
executions and this image of a woman
being served on a platter which was
inspired by the Instagram account of
billionaire Tony tutuni who describes
himself as a quote feminist supporter
and motivational Tyrant my pictures will
make you hate your life or your nagging
wife an absolutely Charming Man I'm sure
but look in the end I've made the
decision not to show the actual Source
images that Togashi used to construct
his drawings in this video because well
honestly it's a bit too messed up some
of them are legitimately scarring
pictures like there's a difference
between seeing takashi's redrawing of it
and an actual photo of a lynching
happening so if you do want to see them
you can look them up they're definitely
out there and it's definitely
interesting that tagashi chose to
reference real life events and if you do
see those images I think it makes
morena's Quest a bit more empathizable
because the world does have truly
horrific events happening everywhere
from the very core of nature all the way
up to the excessive dark desires of the
billionaire class and a lot of what
tagashi has been exploring during his
career as mangaka weirdly in the
specific Shona genre is misanthropy and
I wouldn't necessarily call Togashi
himself a misanthrope but he is more in
tune with the Dark Side of humanity than
most of if not all other Shonen authors
and speaking of Shonen I am
retrospectively shocked that morena's
whole collage was even allowed to be
published in weekly Shonen Jump because
even if these weren't direct
replications of real-life events they're
still pretty damn heavy subjects matter
for an early teen audience but again
this has been a Hallmark of togashi's
work ever since the day's view hakusha
particularly with the chapter black
video tape an artifact from the spirit
world said to contain thousands of hours
of human atrocities committed over
Millennia but why is that relevant for
Hunter Hunter well that's because the
hunter hunter World also has its own
incarnation of the chapter black tape
however in order to truly inspect that
we're going to need to go one layer
deeper